- SO, STEVE, AFTER TWO YEARS
OF TAKING MULTIPLE DAILY SHOTS
IN THE BUTTOCKS, YOU CAN EXPECT
TO GO FROM THIS HAIRLESS FREAK
TO THIS HANDSOME DEVIL.
- WHAT IS THAT,
LIKE, FOUR MORE HAIRS?
- UP TO FOUR MORE HAIRS.
GROWITOL.
ASK YOUR DOCTOR IF GROWITOL'S
RIGHT FOR YOU.
- YOU ARE MY DOCTOR.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
- AM I?
YOU KNOW, STEVE,
I ALWAYS SAW YOU MORE
AS A FRIEND.
BESIDES, I WAS BANNED FROM
PRACTICING MEDICINE YEARS AGO.
[chuckles]
I'M NOT KIDDING.
- ISN'T THERE ANYTHING ELSE
YOU CAN GIVE ME?
WITHOUT HAIR,
I'M NOBODY.
I'M NOT SMART,
I'M NOT AS ATHLETIC AS I LOOK,
MY PERSONALITY
IS NON-EXISTENT,
YET SOMEHOW GRATING.
- WELL, STEVE,
THERE IS THE HAIR TONIC
THAT I USE.
I PURCHASED IT
ON THE CHINESE BLACK MARKET.
OR WAS IT
THE BLACK CHINESE MARKET?
ANYWAY IT'S MADE
WITH TIGER SPERM.
NOW REMEMBER, FRIEND,
JUST RUB A THIMBLEFUL
ON YOUR SCALP ONCE A WEEK--
OOH.
NOT GOOD.
LUCKY FOR YOU,
I'M ALSO A MALPRACTICE ATTORNEY.
MY CARD.
- MAN, IT'S HOT
ALL OF A SUDDEN.
[suspenseful music]
[horn blaring]
[crash]
[door alarm pinging]
WHAT HAPPENED?
MAN, I GOT A WICKED HANGOVER.
OH, GOD.
WHAT HAVE I DONE?
[guns cocking]